it's one day the shirts armholes are
hella small makes me feel like I'm above
and she looks okay
what's the wedgie oh now I realize this
is late I was supposed to post video a
while ago but I got a little confident
what I was doing but I but I really have
to talk about this [ __ ] now for me
growing up the Grammys was something
that I always loved watching I was into
music I wanted to be an army singer then
I found out I had breast and [ __ ] would
you ever trying to sing a song to a girl
and titty [ __ ] at the same time I'm
not talking about me titty [ __ ] it I'll
talk about her titty [ __ ] me
I had this army it called touch my body
it feels like a bag of jell-o but every
year they make a big deal about what
people are wearing not for me I'm not a
fashionista I don't know [ __ ] about
fashion I just know what I like to wear
and what I wants to do with the stuff
that I put on my body which basically
means the same thing is what I like to
wear I just repeat the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing but of course every year when this
should happen there's always somebody
that has to wear something [ __ ]
ridiculous now for the past couple years
the person who has held that title is
Pharrell himself skateboard P now I had
a conversation with a friend the other
day about what this fool Awards the 2015
Grammy Awards I made a couple comments
on Twitter and I said the same joke to
this person and this [ __ ] looked
at me and said well the [ __ ] would you
know what do you know about fashion
first of all [ __ ] don't be coming at me
like that
second of all are you [ __ ] kidding me
tell me what a rail at the Grammys are
like you work for California adventures
open up elevators of [ __ ] you tell me
right now karela good forever like a
[ __ ] Disney cartoon forever like you
wanted with a grand budapest hotel I
swear after a certain point you make so
much money and you have so much
influence on people you could wear
whatever the [ __ ] you want and people
will still say that she does dope I
don't give a [ __ ] what you say I am an
individual human being with my own eyes
and I'll tell you right now [ __ ]
you're like stupid now Pharrell if you
want to work with me in the future
forget what I just said I'm a sellout
anyways [ __ ] yeah in fact I like job
that was pretty cool gold buttons ding
open up and I hate this dumb argument
that this person is he said well you
don't do fashion so how the [ __ ] would
you know anything about their main man
Mary really that's the best thing you
got for other like you work at the Tower
of Terror and you tell me a hungry [ __ ]
about fashion now what does somebody
need to know specifically everything
about fashion in order to have opinion
about clothes that's like you tell me
right now that I don't know what good
food is just based on the fact that I'm
not a chef [ __ ] I don't need to
be a chef to tell you when food tastes
good or not I got two points of
reference point a and point B you tell
Batman he does know about food here's a
huge mistake that a lot of you guys make
out there you think people are fat
because they shove anything in their
mouths no that is not true
we are fat because we selectively choose
what we want to eat and we eat like you
think I go to make tell because I don't
have choices I'm gonna McDonald's
because I love that [ __ ] I would shoot
you for a Big Mac people ever ask you
what would you give up sex or food I'm
beside you have sex this right here is
plenty you can't replace this with a
hamburger I don't know man I feel like
every time somebody becomes a mogul or
they become so successful they can
literally just do whatever and it
doesn't matter because everybody will
think it's dope
and I'm not saying you're that ferrell
of the only one out there that had a
horrible outfit did you look at Rihanna
Rihanna looked like a [ __ ] badminton
wiffle ball coming out looking like a
Jamaican Princess Toadstool you a bottle
of pepto-bismol at Kirby [ __ ] each other
BAM Brianna and don't even get me
started on this other [ __ ] I don't even
know who the [ __ ] she is
I know she's very pretty and she dressed
up as a Roman sex slave I just feel like
at a certain point you just got to make
something so outrageous that it'll get
attention because she dressed up and
that Roman armor and in the back of her
is a de mentor from Harry Potter
expecto patronum your [ __ ] is ugly last
year Pharrell came out with that Yogi
Bear hat and didn't catch on LeBron
tried that [ __ ] but you forgot LeBron
you got a big-ass [ __ ] head that's
just a regular hat on you
I'm just saying some basic [ __ ] it's not
gonna work unless you try to say forest
fires if I ever continue my career music
and I make it to the Grammys I already
know what I'm gonna wear I'm gonna have
a [ __ ] foil ball in my mouth
and wrap my body in saran wrap we call
that a Korean cellophane surprise I know
I think everyone is going on YouTube yes
if you guys notice recently I have been
doing more stuff that you guys have been
asking of me so make sure that you guys
ask questions send me articles give me
topics to talk about cuz I will talk my
[ __ ] dick off just and who knows I
might be working on some other stuff
like shorts and short films and other
stuff stuff etc etc etc so keep it up
give me those topics now give you more
and more content because I am here for
you here for you that's what see my
belly here why it is [ __ ]
Sundays and Wednesdays I'll see you
there you think antivirus what the hell